american actor alec baldwin was told a
prop gun loaded with live rounds was
safe to use that's according to newly
released court records baldwin said he's
shocked and saddened after fatally
shooting a crew member and wounding
another on a film set he described it as
a tragic accident and says he's
cooperating with police as they
investigate
the death of cinematographer helena
hutchins on this movie set in the u.s
has shocked the world
she was rushed to hospital after being
shot in the chest by actor alec baldwin
who didn't know the prop gun was loaded
with live rounds
questions are being raised as to how
such an incident was possible
[Applause]
professionals in the prop industry say
strict protocols may not have been
followed
it is important that there are no live
bullets
if you use live animation for training
actors you do it in a shooting range but
live ammunition has no place on a film
set
us media is reporting that crew members
on the set were complaining about poor
safety conditions and long hours
those workers play a vital role when it
comes to prop gun usage
actors have to remember their lines they
have to remember where to stand to be in
focus so it's really the job of the prop
manager to make sure the actor is going
to use the weapon in a very smooth way
and it's up to us to think about the
safety not the actor
baldwin says he is heartbroken and he
will fully cooperate with the police
investigation
[Applause]
hutchins was known as a rising star in
the industry
directors who worked with her said she
was an incredible talent
i was i was gutted um
i mean pretty much just
broke into tears
right away
um
i mean she was so talented and so young
and with a family so
she grew up in the soviet union and
holds ukrainian citizenship
she leaves behind a husband and a
nine-year-old son
authorities say investigations are
ongoing and that no charges have been
filed
for more now let's bring in joey dillon
he's a weapons advisor on hollywood film
sets and teaches actors gun handling he
joins us now from fraser park california
thanks for joining us so from what we
know so far about this accident we don't
really know that much at this point what
went wrong in your opinion
well first i'm heartbroken there's some
artists out there that i mean it's a
small community and i'm just crushed
it's the worst nightmare situation and
we're all reeling from this i know
there's still
things coming out about it so i i hate
to try to guess uh but i can only speak
from my own experience there's a lot of
safety protocols when i'm armoring a
movie set um there are three ways a gun
can kill somebody on a movie set
one is if you take a blank and you put
it to your head the explosion even
though there's no projectile it doesn't
have anywhere to go so if the gun's up
to your head it'll it'll it could kill
you um the other is if there's a foreign
object in the barrel of the gun and the
bore of the gun is not checked before
loading a blank behind it the blank will
push the projectile out in such a way
that that could be deadly and then the
third way is especially on westerns
based on the type of guns that are used
uh is putting a dummy round which is a
gun a a bullet in the cartridge and
everything that looks
live but is not there's no gun powder in
it there's not a live primer to ignite
the gunpowder and there's even generally
a bb inside of the dummy round so you
can shake it and hear that there's a bb
in there and not only that when you put
it in the gun you can shoot it towards
the floor to display the fact that it is
a fake round but
if a live round was accidentally uh put
in there thinking it was a dummy round
then when you fire it it would obviously
be deadly um
it's
it's just it's very difficult
to fathom how everybody's
you know
but maybe you could explain the safety
precautions just a little bit more for
us i mean even if this wasn't a real gun
in layman's terms
these are pretty dangerous objects so
what do you do on a set to make sure
that this doesn't happen well yeah let
me uh
let me explain so
most of the times the guns are real we
call it you can call them a prop gun
because they're used as a prop but
generally especially when they're
opposed to camera and they have to look
right they're real on a western you're
using revolvers so the difference being
is that on a revolver you see the
cylinder move as you pull the hammer
back on a modern gun the ammunition is
hidden in the magazine so in a revolver
the camera can tell if it's loaded or
not so in order to look loaded you need
to put what looks like authentic live
ammunition in each of the holes of the
cylinder because from the front you can
see the lead bullets and from the side
of the gun you can see the
rims of the shell so
on top of that on a western you've got
everybody walking around with a gun belt
and there's bullets all the way around
that that are supposed to be dummies as
well so you've got dummy bullets
everywhere on a modern movie it's very
rare that you have a dummy round out on
set uh to speak but the protocol would
be clearing the weapon with the first ad
before it goes to an actor and you can
show that it's cold and empty when you
give it to the actor or actress you show
them that it's cold which means empty if
it requires being seen on camera you
could put the dummy rounds in but before
doing so the first ad shakes them and
here's the bb then i put them in the gun
and then i shoot at the ground a bunch
of times to show that nothing happened
then i go show the actor or actress
pointed at the ground i go through all
of them over and over to show nothing
could happen if it's being pointed at
somebody else out to that person i show
them that it cannot go off and on top of
that you've got sometimes a safety
advisor on set but you've got myself
you've also got sometimes a stunt
coordinator is paying attention
sometimes the fire safety officer is
there sometimes the stunt coordinator is
involved with that on top of that you've
got producers that are being mindful of
the crew that's been hired so a lot of a
lot of safety precautions there but
something obviously went terribly wrong
here joey dillon in hollywood gun coach
there thank you for talking to us
you're welcome